[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and man we got a truly insane
chapter here on many levels some
theories were proven right and some
stuff that I really didn't expect and I
really didn't want to happen happened
but whether we successfully predict what
will actually happen or not I really
love theorizing and I know you guys do
too so I'll make a post on our Instagram
and Twitter at anime uproar asking you
guys what you think will happen in the
next chapter chapter 106 this should be
a lot of fun and if you end up being
right I will shout you out in the next
chapter review for being a great
theorize err
as usual I will not use a lot of panels
because I want to avoid getting the
video taken down if possible and there's
the added bonus that you guys get the
video quicker too because there's less
editing involved as always if you want
to discuss the chapter or have any
comments about it let everyone know in
the comments below if you want to see
more attack on titan content give that
like button a colossal smash and
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you never miss an attack on titan
video now let's take a closer look into
the chapter and the unofficial
translation that just came out so this
chapter starts out with our three main
characters armand helps Eren and Mikasa
get on the airship remember last time
they were trying to get away with the
newly acquired Warhammer Titan power I
gotta say that aaron looks very cool
with his long hair facial hair and the
titan lines on his face
the Timescape definitely made him look
more dope ironically though when aaron
gets on the ship
Levi insults him saying he looks
terrible then we get a nostalgic kick
from Levi he kicks Aaron in the face and
tells him that he's under arrest
looks like the relationship between
Aaron and Levi is still very much like
it was before the time skip again Mikasa
has to be held back so that she doesn't
attack Levi but this time she seems more
worried than angry and she lowers her
eyes after showing that Aaron probably
deserved it for I'm
leave acting on his own the way he did
without following instructions from the
higher-ups clearly Mika's has matured
over the course of the time skip and
isn't as worried about making Levi pay
for hurting Aaron this time this is not
to say that she doesn't care about Aaron
as much just that she can see the bigger
picture better than she could before and
sees that Levi actually cares about
Aaron and is doing what he thinks is for
his own good and for everybody's own
good we then see Aaron's face and he
actually looks a lot like kid Levi did
when he was poor and orphaned in the
underground slums after his mother's
death in fact Levi's comments that he's
seen that despicable face in the slums
many times before and says that Aaron
should be happy since things went as he
thought they would but Aaron still seems
down perhaps because he now knows that
his enemies are humans just like him
trying to survive and not embodiments of
pure evil as he previously thought about
Titans and then about moorlands as a
result the innocent lives that he has
taken are probably weighing heavy on his
conscience despite how well his plans
may be going we then jump to gene and
his stylish hair gene says that there
doesn't seem to be weapons on the ground
that can take down the airship which is
lucky for the survey Corps it shows the
power of the air technology in the world
of attack on Titan and how important air
technology will probably be in the rest
of the series unless they develop
technology to effectively counteract it
then row both who seems to have been a
high-ranking official in the garrison
division which maintain and protect the
walls asks gene to simply call him a
fresh recruit possibly to the survey
corps since the garrison is useless and
officials get paid too much
therefore doing nothing this is
definitely true and it shows how far
we've come before when we didn't know
about the truth behind the Titans the
garrison was more justifiable but now
that we know that the only Titans that
can or would break down the walls are
from our lay it makes sense to direct
all the forces at those direct threats
if they eliminate them the wall will be
more than enough to keep the non shifter
Titans usually all less than 15 metres
outside then Connie and Sasha helped
gene back
on the airship we find out that the
survey Corps has six confirmed
casualties and flawed and I'm probably
miss saying his name says that compared
to the damage the enemy took it's a
major victory to the LDN empires first
skirmish so very interesting here it
seems like the people within the walls
are now referring to themselves as the
LDN empire I look forward to seeing how
the official translation translates this
part but it seems that the people in the
wall are moving forward now keeping
their history in mind rather than being
ignorant of it while flaw and the other
recruits are trying to at least act like
they're in high spirits after the
victory Jeanne wonders how many more
battles will have to be fought and how
many more people they'll have to kill as
we know Jeanne has always had more
trouble than most with taking human life
Connie is glad that Jeanne and Sasha are
alive and he hugs Jeanne and Sasha tells
them that they are special to him then
we get a shot of Sasha's face she
tenderly touches Connie's arm and smiles
Connie and Sasha's relationship has
definitely developed and at this point
it seems like they really do like each
other more than just friends then we
jump to Falco and Gaby and they're
chasing the airship as usual Falco is
trying to calm Gaby down just as Mekas I
used to try to calm Aaron down when they
were kids but as we know Aaron stayed
mad and wanted to kill the Titans when
he was young and Gabi is the same her
hatred is just directed towards the
survey corps Gabi comments how her best
friends judo and Sofia died because of
the survey corps now a lot of people
commented that they hate Gabi in the
comments of other videos and you may
still hate her after this but here we
get ISA AMA giving us her side of the
story how she was treated terribly she
was spat on and people did other
horrendous things to her because she was
LDN but she wanted to prove that
Aldean's could be nice people to the
world so she worked really hard hoping
to help the people close to her and
because of the survey corps or the
island dwelling LD ends
she lost lives of many people that were
important to her and she feels that
everything she worked so hard for is now
gone she even points out how Zee
died in front of them and Gabi as a
member of the younger generation doesn't
even know why any of this happened why
the island dwellers are so cruel to them
Falco tries to explain that the people
on the island paradise were invaded by
Marley and that countless people were
killed
he tells Gabi that they are doing it for
revenge but Gabi says she didn't see
Marley invade the island and neither did
Falco then instead of facing the
complexity that there are good and bad
guys on all sides and that the survey
corps attack on Marley was the result of
Marley's attack on them
Gabi resorts to the stories that the
Marley and children have been
brainwashed from an early age to believe
instead of entertaining Falco's idea she
labels the island dwelling LD ins as
Devils who threaten world peace that
always deserved to die and that are
fundamentally different from the more
layin LD ins to me this scene is one of
the saddest you have Gabby struggling to
maintain her sense of justice struggling
to maintain her hatred while evidence
keeps stacking up that fundamentally
challenges her worldview Falco gets a
flashback of air and telling Reiner that
they're the same across the seas within
the walls were all the same this is in
stark contrast with how Gabby thinks now
and how Aaron thought as a kid again we
see just how much Aaron has matured and
how he has been able to move beyond his
hatred and acknowledge that these people
who attacked his people killed his
mother and made his life a living hell
are just as human as him this is no
small Epiphany and we should really
acknowledge how hard that must have been
for him to do and that is exactly what
gabby is struggling with now Gabby
ignoring Falco runs closer to the
airship Roe both the older ex garrison
official sees her and aims at her but he
cannot bring himself to shoot because
she is a child
Gabby shoots and headshots him sending
him falling to the ground his dead body
is still connected to the ship and Gabby
decides to use it to get on board and
tried to kill all the Devils from the
island she is okay with dying clearly
these child soldiers have been trained
to think highly of being martyrs Cole
shows up and is running towards his
brother when Gabby uses the 3d
maneuvering gear to start climbing up to
board the ship and falco grabs on in the
last minute gabby asks why and falco
says the person who inherit the armored
Titan is me again the only reason he
wants to do that is so he can protect
her from it so again he shows us how all
of his actions are centered around
protecting Gabby and trying to save her
from a dark future then something too
messed up happens and this is what I did
not see coming and really did not want
to happen
Gabby gets on board and shoots killing
potato girl she kills sasha gene and
connie are mortified as she's dying and
of course sasha thinks about supper and
meat reminding us of those more innocent
days when they were in the training
corps and sasha got into trouble over
stealing food then she appears to die
man like I can't believe it some of you
speculated that gene might die but Sasha
I really did not want her to die this is
messed up she was like Jill one of my
favorite characters but clearly this
month likes reminding us that fan
favorites aren't even safe and I feel so
bad for Connie in particular I really
wanted to see their relationship develop
after that moment they had earlier in
this chapter and after that it's all the
more devastating that her life was cut
short and obviously emma is aware of
that but rest in peace Sasha potato girl
you will be missed what an emotional
chapter this one is then we jump down to
the Marlins Magath is looking for Gabby
and Falco in the meantime Peake is
struggling to heal she reveals that she
remembered who the Marlin soldier was
that led her and gallier to the pit it
was a soldier sent on our reconnaissance
unit sent to Paradise Island after
Ryan's group a reconnaissance unit that
disappeared this means that there may be
many more Marlin deck soldiers working
for the island dwelling LD ins since
they clearly didn't simply kill them all
next we jump back to the plane and that
ex parte layin soldier jelena takes off
her fake beard when Levi comments on it
we have Gabby freaking out as Jean
is about to bring her to Levi and the
rest
she says that the will left by war chief
Zeke will be carried on by our comrades
then back down to peak who says that she
took interest in Jelena because she was
so devoted to Zeke
back to a close-up of Zeke surprise
surprise on the airship Gabi is confused
thinks they captured Zeke
hanji comes out of a door and asks if
everything went according to plan
Zeke Jaeger and he says yes in its
essence but there were too many
miscalculations like Gabi getting on the
ship now yes here we have something that
I've been saying since the Marlin Ark
started Zeke is far too intelligent
arguably the most intelligent character
according to the attack on Titan
handbook tied with hanji to go along
with them are laying plans that would
clearly not benefit LD ins I knew he was
masterminding a awesome plan and we
called that he was not dead and of
course he wasn't that by the way would
have been like the most anticlimactic
death in anime history if if it was true
but thankfully it's not anyways it is
hilarious to see Zeke and Levi two of
the most awesome characters in the manga
and former enemies joking around seek
even jokes that he'll piss himself if
Levi stares at him like that which is
just hilarious mostly because it's
probably true but Levi says he always
leaves his favorite dish til last
because he wants to savor it so clearly
there is still tension here and they're
not
buddy-buddy all of a sudden but the fact
that they are on the same side for the
time being is very cool I mean who could
stop these two guys when they're working
together
hanji also says some insightful things
near the end of the chapter like that
the world will mobilise full force
against Paradis Island that they always
rescued Aaron from the enemies in the
past no matter how many died and despite
knowing that he came up with this
suicidal strategy using himself as bait
she says that they lost all trust for
Aaron after the stunt but Zeke points
out
that they got the founding Titan n1 with
royal blood meaning himself together the
losses will be worth it since the plan a
Zeke admits is the freedom of the LD ins
side note it's cool to see these
brothers both sons of Griha Jager
finally on the same side I think they'll
be able to do some really crazy things
together then Connie comes in to let
everyone know that Sasha is definitely
dead with tears streaming from his eyes
gene points out that she died because of
Aaron and Aaron looks devastated
remembering a younger Sasha who wanted
to retrieve lost lands so they'd have an
abundance of cows and sheep I like it
that they left off with the memory of
Sasha because that was a huge debt and
it is easy to say that losses are
inevitable in war but it is different
when the cost is the life of someone
you've grown up with and have shared
your goals and aspirations with a Zeke
says in essence everything went
according to plan but lives including
many innocent lives were lost and I
think as Jean points out in the
beginning this is only the first battle
it is foreshadowing a lot more deaths to
come before freedom can be reached so
wow what a frickin chapter guys what do
you think what is the plan
how will they be fighting all the forces
of the world that will be coming for
them on Paradis what is Zeke's master
plan does Zeke know how to use his royal
blood with Aaron's founding Titan the
ability to actually control other Titans
including maybe the wall Titans do you
think that Aaron's suicidal plan was
worth it remember to let me know what
you think will happen in the next
chapter on the Instagram or Twitter post
at anime uproar and you may be featured
in the next review if you liked this
review colossal smash that like button
and subscribe and hit that notification
bell for more attack on Titan videos
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]